it's a new book explores how parents
anxiety can affect their children's
well-being
nearly 1 in 3 adults and 1 in 3 children
aged 13 to 18 will experience an anxiety
disorder over the course of their
lifetime psychologist Madeleine Levine
is the author of love this title ready
or not preparing our kids to thrive in
an uncertain and rapidly changing world
she says the need to protect your kids
from discomfort is setting future
generations up to fail and madeline
levine joins us at the table Madeline
you know it's such as a parent it's such
a natural instinct I want to protect you
I want to make sure you're okay and you
say that is not so good so there's all
different kinds of protection cards
coming at your kids you want to protect
them what you don't want to do is
protect them from the normal things that
happen in life because how do we get
prepared for a challenge like this
challenging just spoke to 500 people
asked is anybody in the audience never
had a broken heart one person raised
their hand you will have a broken heart
you will have challenge in life and in
order to be able to not fall apart with
that so we just let them fail we just
let them you you let them fail at the
normal developmental thing things kid
once go to wait a camp and he's scared
he's supposed to be a first experiences
on a bike he's supposed to be a little
nervous it's the first experience how do
you get better in anything you master
the fear yeah right you talked a lot
about anxiety anxiety between the
parents and the children right right so
we know principle 30% of anxiety
disorders is genetic it surprises me
it depends 30 to 40 depends which
Madeleine you're looking at us like of
course it is really 30 to 40 so this is
whole science epigenetics it's where
genetics and the environment intersect
and turn on something so you probably
have a gene somewhere in you somebody in
your family might have been anxious or
depressed or something like that does
that gene turn on or not and that
depends in part on the environment so
you put a kid in a really stressful
environment I have one kid from a
colleague who taking calculus in high
school father is grad
thing every single test this young man
can you think he calculus that's not the
kid has trichotillomania he's pulling
out his hair he's pulling out its
eyelashes he's pulling out his eyebrows
and the dad says he'll stop when he
finishes calculus
no he won't that's the way he learned to
deal with anxiety you believe that we
can get back to a place where we're
anxiety isn't as prevalent in diagnoses
as it's become so when I wrote a book
called the price of privilege twelve
years ago anxiety disorders hit one in
five now anxiety disorders are hitting
one in three what what happened I mean
genetics don't change in twelve years
something has happened in the
environment and I think it's because
it's incredibly uncertain people don't
know how to deal with it they're very
anxious we've got social media which is
constant comparison we've got pressure
on kids the number one anxiety provoking
thing for a child is school it you
believe that yeah I believe that Aaron I
want to go to the title the second line
of your book preparing our kids to
thrive in an uncertain and rapidly
changing world so madeline levine dr.
Maddaloni how do we do that to prepare
them how do we prepare them yes I think
we do a couple things we're willing we
love them obviously you know we know
that that's that love in limits are
really good for kids I think we start
encouraging things that prepare them for
an uncertain future that would be
something like risk tolerance so you
have a kid and you're nervous about
having him go around the block right on
his bike because who knows it might be
somebody in the bushes yeah you have to
tolerate your own anxiety and let the
kid manage it if he's eight or nine or
ten years old so you allow situations
and encourage and challenge what about
older kids we get it as a little kid on
a bike what about older kids what about
older kids so teenagers young adults
like what you're trying to do is get
them to make understand the calculus the
difference between drinking and driving
which is a bad risk and trying out for
the lead in the school play you want
them to have those kinds of experiences
that are challenging there's a fabulous
experiment where you take two groups of
kids
and you tell one group how incredibly
smart and talented they are and you
don't tell the other group anything who
does better it's the group that you
don't tell anything to because they
don't have all the pressure of living up
to standards right right and also it
depends on your what you talk about
people say well we're not talking about
metrics and good jobs and good schools
anymore and then you go to the dinner
table and they're talking about bonuses
and who has a Tesla same things at an
environment madeleine levine thank you
so much my pleasure
ready or not is on sale wherever books
are sold